(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Our founding
fathers were booze hounds.
(clinking glasses)
So much so, that Benjamin
Franklin published
a dictionary of 228 words
that all describe one thing,
being blind drunk in the 13 colonies.
- [Founding Father] We love to drink.
- [Narrator] Colonial Americans
were perpetually bombed,
especially since water wasn't always
clean and accessible.
- [Man] Aww, gross.
- [Narrator] Many of our
nations most respected men
could be found with a
glass or two in hand.
In fact, Thomas Jefferson drafted
the Declaration of Independence
- [Jefferson] Ah, yes. Oh, whoops.
- [Narrator] while drunk on Madeira.
George Washington racked
up an epic bar tab
of over 160 bottles for just 54 delegates.
- [Franklin] It's on me.
- [Narrator] And John
Adams went on a seven week
binge, drinking six hours a
night with younger congressmen.
- [Adams] Keep drinking, keep drinking.
- [Narrator] So Franklin
took a stab at his peers
and published the terms
he overheard at local pubs
in the Drinkers Dictionary.
Here's what they said.
- I've got corns in my head.
- Oh, go eat a pudding bag, Thomas.
- You're one to talk Washington
You're as dizzy as a goose.
- I'm jambled.
- My goodness Hamilton,
you've got a brass eye today.
- Well, the King was his cousin.
- Clearly gentlemen, you're all wasted.